in time with Reza palavi a couple times
the sun in DC we've had a meeting
together we sat down we talked about his
father we did a zoom a couple years ago
and we've spoken you should have him on
you should have money you should have
money on he's out there very you know
eloquent great speaker does very good
job but the the audience is 50 50. if
you look at his social media it gets a
lot of people gets a lot of commentary
he gets a lot of people that still
follow him you know a very loyal to his
messaging but what what is the
perspective of Reza pallavi's you know
his son RP uh how do the Persian Iranian
people view him
any one of you guys can take this one if
you're well I live in L.A okay so la
leans toward more monarchists but
there's also a lot of people like me who
aren't aligned or affiliated with any
group ideology or person we just want
freedom for Iran and I know
um
some some of the people in his Camp have
said look he just would like to be a
part of the democracy and in an election
and if they vote for him great and if
they don't it'll be somebody else so
there's kind of different camps and
there is definitely split support that's
what I've seen
yeah I agree uh when uh last couple of
times he cleared his vision about you
know what I want to be a citizen and if
people wanted me to run the country no
problem uh then you guys selected right
this made the so much clearer for people
that are thinking like only King only
Reza only there's a show is coming this
this way now people know that we talk
about absolute democracy absolute
democracy when regime change everybody
vote on what they want to do
I think it's more 50 50 because I don't
know if the younger people feel he can
relate to their pain because he's lived
in America and and you know I think the
generation that knows his father more
they're probably saying oh we would like
that back but the younger generation I
don't know
I'm not 100 I would agree with that as
well you don't know if the younger
generation which is very valid on why
that would be the case well listen to
their chance too the younger generation
is just saying
freedom dust of the dictator doesn't
regime don't be scared we're all
together so that I just feel like if we
listen to their chance we can hear what
they want freedom secularism secular
democracy but there's not one person's
name some people say it in Iran but the
majority are not saying one person's
name it's kind of like for example we
moved to Florida right and I was having
a conversation with SIA and then we we
talk about California how we miss
California but we miss California post
covet because that's the California we
know California is different for us now
because we're so used to Florida are you
kidding me and I feel like for example
the older generation remembers how Iran
was with Shaw and palavi all of that and
they're hoping that comes back but is
there a connection with the youth is he
making is RP making connection with the
youth or whenever there is uprise that's
when he shows up that's the whole
question got it so you know some view as
an opportunist hey come out here say a
few things some say no we want them here
because we'd like to go back and see
what Iran once used to be the chance of
Iran going back to a monarchy is slim to
none it's not that it's not going to be
a monarch the only thing that's going to
happen is a again my opinion I'm just
talking from my perspective here on what
I'm saying uh uh democracy is the only
uh uh in order for him to take it back
to monarchy I feel you can't be
disconnected for 43 that's a long time
for it to happen again so again no one
knows you'll see what happened if it
comes down to the election that's who
they want it is what it is if it doesn't
it won't happen I think John people
experienced 1400 years ago Islam uh
that's enough for them they don't want
to go experience 250 years ago myarchy
yeah again
it's time for democracy
and freedom but what does democracy look
like
what did we find out
how do you live here no I understand but
think about 44 years of Oppression how
do you gradually do that right how how
what does that look like how long does
it take because it's not going to happen
overnight think about it horses
overnight of course it's not gonna
happen overnight it's gonna take a while
yeah
but it is possible because it's
different type of movement this time
than the green green movement and green
movement I feel like I actually was in
Iran when that happened I got to Iran
two days before the election with
ahmadina Jordan musavi and it was when I
when we landed we were out of the
airport in Tehran at 2 A.M and we're
driving through the streets and
everybody's out dancing there's green
everywhere because that was the color of
the movement music and I was like so
shocked I asked my family I was like
this is happening here this is legal
right now and they're like well yeah
it's before the election so they want
everybody to feel this energy and
everybody really felt energized and we
all saw what happened it was a
ringed election obviously and went to
amany John but those and I was there for
the couple weeks after so I saw what
happened but it did kind of get quashed
pretty quickly this one has sustained
and it's showing no signs of slowing
down especially because we're talking
about different sectors of businesses
now joining together
um to protest so that's one big
difference another one is like how young
the people are that are engaged and
moving this forward to like teenagers
were saying you know I just haven't seen
it be this sustained because we've had
protests happen but Auburn happened that
was the nov bloody November in 2019 or
1500 people that we know of were killed
um and then that because the internet
got throttled and cut off and the world
wasn't paying the attention it is now
that also got quelled really easily and
this one is not this one's growing more
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]